hi everybody welcome to analyze this the
cluster finally starts so today we're
gonna start with Julien's game and he
was blacking and someone who was known
as non Julian we don't know who it is
the guys say there was 1900 so we're
gonna analyze it and we're going to
actually do it we can't do it the proper
way because the proper way to do it is
to analyze it once by yourself and try
to think of the best way the best moves
and everything without outside
assistance and then I'd like to do it
while I'm adding like stockfish in the
background for blunder check and to see
you know assessments although of course
you cannot count on the opponent on the
computer for openings here without the
benefit of having super time to do the
game properly we're going to pretend
that we've gone over it and we're going
to start analyzing it with cheating so
we have efore oh yeah of course
efore c59 of 3 d6 d4 so far so normal
takes takes 9 of 6/9 III ok he actually
played not f6 Knight c3 first to avoid
any lines with f3 I suppose sometimes
one of the things that I used to do in
this position after d4 if they take take
not f6 apply f3 which is not a great
plan but it can be a surprise for a lot
of people so another is very popular is
to play the move order 9 f6 and really
white there's nothing better than to
play Knight c3 and then pawn takes we
have transposed but we get to this
position anyways and your opponent plays
the move a 6 so we have a nod of
Sicilian so you play the move a 6 and we
still have a matter of design
okay so I'll very briefly explain a
little bit in really on the tip of a
fork like they say the idea of the move
a six because this move looks like a
very strange mode well the original idea
was to play the move a e5 in this
position but if you play the movie five
white is a very good opportunity to play
the
Bishop to b5 check and the reason is
that now this vacates the f5 square for
the night without being captured so what
do you block the bishop this way or if
you play this with the bishop whatever
you do my knight is gonna end up on the
f5 square so for example if we see a
line like this like this like this and
like this and again if black does
nothing then white will go Bishop g5
take the knight go 93 and put a horse on
d5 forever it's gonna be a tremendous
game for white there's no question about
that that's very easy to see if he is
gonna end up against this Bishop that
Bishop will be no comparison so then
they realize that this is a favorable
variation for white and Knight I've
decided that he is gonna better the plan
by playing a6 he can afford to play
excuse me a tempo loss of a temple
because h6 is a pretty relevant moving
the Sicilian anyways because it supports
b5 and it stops Knight d2 b5 in someone
it's a very logical man so now why it
says themself ok do I allow a5 or not so
in this game white plays a move that
discourages if I very much he played the
move Bishop to g5 one of the main lines
if we add hours maybe we can discuss
some other moves but it's it's for a
fact that when you play a move like
Bishop to e3 or Bishop to e2 black has
the choice of playing a six or a five in
this period of the night off after
Bishop g5 however he 5 becomes a move
that's less desirable because as you can
see that goes directly into a pin and
again d5 is completely owned by white it
just illogical so the normal move to
play is to play is to play east sex just
to avoid lines with Bishop takes f6 and
but here black played the lesser-known
Knight bg7
although very playable line and to tell
you I'm an expert on this time will be a
total lie because this is really one of
the worldís lines but in the old days
and let me see if I'm correct about it
when I'll check it with a reference the
most challenging move to this idea was
to play the move Bishop c4 and if your
opponent played up as we play something
else
you play Bishop e2 ok so not the most
dangerous time but now this is a good
time to hit reference
in reference to usually like I said
should be connected to a good database
and here now here it's a good idea if
you see in the bottom right you see it
says top games so it's very smart to hit
top games because we don't respect to L
just players I really don't care what
Rufus and doofus who are rated about
three and a half points versus three and
a half points played I prefer to see
what the strong players played so now I
see up on top that every logical move
has been played recently including
recently after 2010 because this is how
updated this database is like buying
yesterday's paper
so you considered the main movies Bishop
c4 played by rod and then Roger but we
see all the big names on top but all the
way to the to the bottom even a move
like a common move like not coming but a
quiet of like g3 was played by in a body
in a body is an Israeli Grandmaster
pretty decent player at 2010 maybe he
wasn't a grandmaster but still an
up-and-coming youngster and we can see
here a bunch of interesting games so now
two things can happen if you are really
interested in this in searching the
opening then it's a very wise idea to
look at the options to look at games in
all kinds of moves and then we select
our move Bishop e2 and we see all the
possible answers ok this is also a high
time to bring our cousin stockfish 5
into the fray ok you can already see
that Bishop e2 lost a lot of the
credence here right before with Bishop
c4 we would have had lots of games and
strong grandmasters you can choose
Nakamura and all the few you already
lost all of them so lucky neither so you
decided to play the movie 6 ok very
legitimate ok I can complain your
opponent did he do something he Castle
ok
so already I can tell you that we have
transposed into a variation in the shiva
lingam defense it's aligned in the
Sicilian where white is playing a
somewhat of a hybrid system he brings
his Bishop to e2 Castle kingside but he
put the bishop on g5 that's almost
always not a good idea because he is
mixing is basically mixing the system
the idea Bishop g5 is
to Castle queenside for white so the
normal line would have been to try to
play a variation with a Bishop to c4 and
many times you know to try to bring the
Queen up and then castle go left
now when you Castle here it's gonna be
awfully hard to send your pawns
attacking here and if you want to attack
with your pawns here then why is your
bishop in the way like the best plan in
this running here for white is to put
the bishop on e3 or to put it back on c1
doesn't matter and to play f4 and then
at some point to play g4 and g5 now all
of a sudden this plan is kind of out so
not very smart so I think you play
Bishop e7 which is the most normal move
no complaint about that and now your
opponent decided to play the move Bishop
to e3 am i right so of course this move
is not going to be mentioning the
reference because nobody in his right
mind will play Bishop g5 with the idea
Bishop e3
but I can already tell you oh wait a for
re 4 was the game in the reference right
yeah I forget that I didn't have to put
no again so Bishop e3 alright so you can
see already that the reference won't
block blank that means you have no games
to look at now you're basically
independent that's a new position okay
or at least on this database nobody
played so I can go back to notation
doesn't really matter you can see the
reference actually I like to really
reference on because sometimes you can
see like a blank reference and then as
the games in the game progresses it
transposes to unknown position then
games can somehow appear probably it's
not going to happen here but it's still
worth doing it so we have Bishop e3
basically after black castles but she
does we have a theoretical position
that's not what I meant
very good we have a theoretical position
where black is playing up a tempo
because white oh and Bishop to g5 at any
one Bishop to e3
of course since the position is quite
playable for black now it's even more
playable so let's see what why did he
play our four eventually not yet it
plays Queen d2 okay in itself a
reasonable move I think and you played
Queen c7 of course black wants to play
the move beef
five but B five in this position will be
a very very bad idea
both because of ninety-six forking the
Queen and the bishop that's really a
silly idea to give up this bishop for
this night this is such a good defensive
measure and also there are ideas of
Bishop af3 on the long diagonal and
white threatens to play e5 which is
again not something that we wanted to do
although normally that happens when this
night is back home now with the knight
is here maybe now it can come to e5 but
okay can argue the move Queen c7 Queen
c7 is a very good man okay so for a
black is playing this game perfectly I
have no complaints f4 very nice if you
notice on the right side we can see that
games we have games joining us somehow
this transpose into something normal but
if you think that this is great for
white then I suggest you look what
stockfish things about it already is
think that black is considerably better
and he has to play the move b5 and of
course black played be fine so again if
you were just optically looking at the
position we can already see that black
who usually has his initiative on the
Queen side and tries to hold the center
is coming first in other words already
my first immediate threat is to play
before the night is gonna have to move
and little Suzy on e4 is bye-bye
and it's just I'm picking the poem for
nothing and attacking the Queen on top
of everything so not white this to start
playing very sheepishly you could play
Bishop f3
then of course Bishop to b7 developing
the last minor piece towards the center
I think that black is just sitting very
pretty here I don't know how the game
continued but we'll figure it out very
shortly he played I had this happen
actually Bishop f3 sorry Bishop e7
that's logical and now very very
concerned about the move before he
played the move a 3 as a rule of thumb
and again I don't mean in every
variation ever in this is same but
there's a rule of thumb if black has
upon on b5 and white is upon a
three-block won the battle because if
you wanted to stop b5 then you should
have played the pawn to a4 and cut the
pawn back before he gets to advance now
black has several good plans let's see
what he chose I'm thinking to myself
well the computer says Knight c5 but I
have to tell you that I would have
played the move Knight
six huh you did I like it yeah yeah
actually serious players also playing
with the black pieces you know got a
compliment 95 so 95 yeah I wasn't sure
what's gonna happen after E 5 but the
computer really likes I suggesting 94
okay so here's my concern I usually
notice the Queen c7 97 these things they
are designed to stop a mysterious
advance here after this move I was a bit
concerned what happens with this because
notice that the Queen now is a bit
overloaded it's taking care of ePHI
behind its pawn but it's also
babysitting the bishop on b7 but
evidently here there's not much concern
because the computer suggests this this
and this and again just by looking at
the position you can tell the black is
in really good shape the e4 e5 pawn is
isolated the black pieces of swarm are
swarming the center the King looks very
very safe and all the businesses on the
center move Queen side where of course
black has an advantage yeah black is
assessing this position as black is
almost up upon that is very nice very
easy to understand white is just
completely discombobulated here okay so
that did not happen or did it what
happened here he played Queen to e1 no
oh because you play 96 I'm sorry I
forgot you didn't play 95 okay so Knight
b6 okay
Knight b6 to me this is a very very
logical continuation I'm interested in
putting my knight on c4 my knight on g4
is gonna hit the bishop the Queen and
pawn b2 very hard to disagree with that
kind of a setup really really gonna like
it
okay the computer suggests rook 81 with
the idea of Quincy 1 I'm pretty certain
again that anybody that sees it after
rook D 194 Queen c1 the Queen on c1 is
just not living a good impression black
is clearly superior in that position
alright so let's see what happened he
played Bishop - is it after you
Bish's f - okay and you continue with
nicéphore I'm assuming yeah and Quincy
won
how is it you won Quincy won
all right now black is really in good
shape but we have to consider that at
some point there's going to be denied
might be chased later so we have to pay
attention to that right now I don't
think it's a case because the knight on
c3 is going to be left undefended so
that gives me at least one move but I
can play lots of useful moves here my
favorite move would have been to play
one of the routes to the C file this way
I'm threatening Knight takes b2 and okay
I see the computer is also agreeing and
notice that the computer would be for
thought 95 was superior than I'd be 6
now all of a sudden he is back into is
conforming again so Lucchesi it very
nice black is really sitting pretty
let's see so he played Knight d2 e -
okay everybody sort of threw out 90 X b2
Queen takes b2 Queen takes c3 extra pawn
with a better position and of course
this knight on c3 can't really afford to
run away because pawn before is
babysitted so now everything is cramped
the knight is defending the knight
that's defending the pawn needless to
say that I would rather be black in that
position okay again a moment of crisis
in the position and I'm Billy I'm a big
believer in the statement if Black gets
to play d5 then he has solved these
opening problems now of course when I
say play d5 there's got to be that
little Asterix saying that and get away
with it right it's like I know wise I
can also play d5 in any position but
then I can lose it also but here I see
no reason not to play d5 what are the
computers are the committee says d5 and
the computer also likes rook f d8 also a
logical move the last okay this is
developed this is developed this is
developed this is developed only the
rook on f8 is a bit sleepy rook d8 and
of course d5 seems to be almost
inevitable but I'm really dying to play
the move d5 now just shutting this
Bishop out just breaking in the center
of getting this Bishop alive
taking more pressure on the queenside so
it's talking good did you play differ
okay I mean I can't really complain
about it no it's like normally d5 is
like a really good strike in the center
I don't even know what he's gonna do in
this position the point is normally e5
is the slap but you can see that I can
jump right in
before define yeah I don't know if it
really makes a big difference let's take
a look so people here
yeah uh-huh well I see at least one
difference and I had to cheat actually I
looked at the computer before I had a
chance to think for myself
he can play b3 now after d5 he could not
have played he could not apply b3 yeah
first of all he has to worry about me
taking on e4 right
he takes d4 looks just horrendous taking
the bishop afterwards you see what I'm
talking about and talk about the
position prior here if I play d5 if
black if Y tries to play this move well
there's like about million wins here
every move wins starting with this this
must win at least upon look at that the
computer I mean white is not down a
piece but the computer says that he's
worse than down a piece well I can take
on c3 right on c4 but this is just
horrendous this is just you don't know
it's really the analyzing this is just
freaked out because it's just horrible
so the point was now we understand the
urgency of d5 when Luke d8 was played
then white had the time to play the move
b3 not that this is a pretty picture but
it's not not as bad as it could have
been I suppose
okay so now you played oh you didn't
play me 300
Wow how could you pass on this method
the whole point of playing this move was
to play b3 as well huh Wow very
interesting well this would have been of
course more challenging he sends the
knight back then the Queen can come from
its shelter maybe Queen III or something
and look it's obvious that black will
always be better because of the
fundamental weaknesses of white on the
Queen side and black
Oh black is not facing an attack at all
at least not yet and d5 is really at any
move so yeah
okay so 93
okay so Luke takes them before and
all right so let's see can I can i okay
let me see if I go here here here here
is this this one what the community's
not impressed by this idea but black it
was always better I think black was 0.60
in the other variation also oh here it
says rook d1 now basically wants to say
okay you have an extra pawn but it's
here it's vulnerable it's always subject
to falling and white just keeps on
playing and it's is defending very
interestingly the pawn here this is weak
so of course black is better and here's
an extra pawn I have half a pawn but
notice how the assessment dropped down a
little bit it's like point four or
something and now it's even point three
yeah it's understandable because I mean
you don't get a queen this pawn that is
the problem so realistically if you
compare this position we'll call it
position a and if you just retreat I
mean any retreat is just gonna maintain
your advantage because d5 again
unstoppable unstoppable then again if
I've tonight just hopped in to e4 and
we're not afraid of a capture so our
opponent didn't do it what did he do
Brooke d1 or something okay Brooke d1
okay so again d5 did you play d5
yay d5 came in very good black is taking
over I like that so he took
and I have to say that now the computer
suggested to move that I didn't see oh
he changed back to eat xd5 but for a
moment he was suggesting Bishop c5
Bishop to c5 which would have been like
wow really inside anybody interesting
but I have to stop and explain that move
even though it's not the main move right
now but it's what oh now it is the main
move again and the point is that it
looks like why can white keep taking
stuff but I think that after a check
here followed by Queen check on the
diagonal the White King is growing on a
trip that he is not not gonna like so
much so you see for example well now
he's back to e d5 but doesn't matter
let's just examine this and here this
has to be just horrible I guess take
oops takes just to explain takes and
check perhaps here yeah that looks good
enough yeah I know what I want to be in
this position the white king is going to
travel either to g3 or to e1 if you go
to f1 93 check looks like curtains yeah
obviously look at the black pieces look
at the white pieces look at the space
advantage and this game this King is
sitting on a on the lawn chair somewhere
and this guy is like in the open in the
breeze not good so back we go
and he says II d5 and you play BB five
as well right or yeah very very good
okay
well done now your opponent goes on and
does now it does b3 hard to believe that
this move can be right here hard to
believe yeah
listen he needs to at least the one
benefit that he got from the sequence
even though black opened all the lines
and the bishop is gonna jump here and
the night is gonna jump here and of
course it's obvious that black is better
but at this might get a little little
gift here that he can put one of his
pieces maybe his knight or Bishop I
don't know what is the computer said by
the way oh he wants both okay but both
he says black is better obviously after
Bishop d4 Bishop c5 again that Square is
not as influential as all the lines and
the knight coming to e4 and that pretty
Knights inning on c4 very very good for
black instead they decide to do this
be a blunder right of some sorts now wow
I need the computer doesn't like to take
on a three I thought that the whole
point was to take on e3 and you did that
yeah but that looks like the most normal
but the computer says you know what
chill out with that just go 96 and 94
and the rule comes to the open file and
life is just grand
okay so again black is better you know
those variations after 96 the computer
is just so completely crazy about the
position but I want to see why this was
not good okay so he talked and before
did he move okay for yeah and takes I
thought that this is actually an
improvement to the version before
because you have another deep on here
and okay but we'll see what happened of
course black is still better there's no
question about it
now maybe Bishop D for now is a bit
annoying Bishop d4 Bishop c5 now black
is better but I guess I guess the
computer doesn't appreciate this poem so
much because even though it's an extra
pawn it doesn't again not going anywhere
and this needs some babysitting and so
they notice that the computer who is
notoriously material greedy is
preferring not to take the material not
to win the pawn just retreat with the
knight to emphasize the central control
just leave that broken is oblivion back
on a one as opposed to being active here
so he's assessing White's activity as
compensation for the pawn okay that's
interesting it's hard to disagree so
what did he do usually I'm pretty good
at deciphering Scotia's but this one is
tough okay maybe this is 94 it's
possible
seriously 94 first but now it's fighting
me white played by d4 sorry
and then here like that okay I'll see it
if it doesn't work then I'll show you
the score [ __ ] okay ah so this is the
position now you went here okay that's
different that's different that's also
very good for black okay you know you
went here okay
oh my god but 92 yeah what is it
computer side to computer oh my god 92
is just winning oh my gosh
yeah that's that's a hard move to meet
92 is really hard to meet did you
consider it an all or no it's not a very
intuitive move but look at this guy if
you would have played here what exactly
is he doing now the immediate threat is
to play among other things as g6 also
this monistic and that I'm not even
talking about Knight xf3 completely
spoiling the haircut here you know it's
gonna look like a really funny pawn
structure with a poem from g2 going to
athletes oh of course black is just
totally winning this is just really easy
okay so in the game g6 okay in you
mainline the funny thing is that it's
like no matter how many slight
inaccuracies this is thought so much
better for black fundamentally that
white cannot I think that in the long
run white is gonna lose anyway so I
think that we have it right now g6
Bishop takes something Oh
well isn't he losing some lame
now I think he had to have played 94 or
something no why didn't he just go back
night to d4 yeah of course it's position
he's miserable but this is this is the
you know that's that's the the student
he cooked for himself working in there
okay so he just decided to give you more
stops and Bishop takes of course maybe
expect that Queen takes Knight d4 and
everything is cool you forgot that the
night rolls backwards now that's gonna
be expensive that's gonna be very
expensive okay now there's only thing
that I don't understand now after Knight
takes e5 why did the game lasted so many
more moves after that he didn't resign
okay
so here you played 94 takes takes did he
go rookie eight like lucky you supposed
to know Queen b6 okay the computer is
not too mad about that either Queen b6
Queen e3 I guess to get through here to
the tempo okay in d3
oh you would have had to pay me not to
play rook c4 here what did you do yeah
this is that come of this kind of begs
to be blade whoopsie sorry okay black is
crushing okay the rest we're looking for
historical value only
he played h3 not my favorite move but
what can you do and you took here it
says you take something maybe root k4
yeah why not you're not gonna come see
me complaining so he took here and you
played rook c8 I'm not really analyzing
this very carefully because it just
makes no sense I mean why should resign
here with the clear conscience
he is done material he has no position
no compensation it just I think he's
playing like by some sort of inertia
maybe because it's just like time
trouble or something or okay only thing
is that he is no position that so
oh no not too smooth you weren't here
okay so just c3 now okay he did seek me
and now you played Queen c5 okay why not
do it with a cheaper piece like that and
then take here
I'm being very picky because every move
wins but it's just that this move looks
economical so Quincy five king h2 yeah
probably not the best move in the world
but what can you apply roof takes III do
we have to see the end all right we'll
do it in speedy fashion Queen d2 at this
point I usually stop because this is
just like you know cruelty to animals
so here and he played Knight to b3 and
you play it Queen to c7 it couldn't be
six mixed emotions hit the night now but
again I'm being super picky Bishop takes
d5 Knight oh you took on d5 okay Queen
takes d5 everything wins Queen takes f4
Chuck and he played King H 1 ok 3 yeah
in this position there's a very famous
Grandmaster bad name of Roman ginger
cache really you must have heard of him
he is a very good quote that's very
valid here he said I'm looking but I
can't find a move that doesn't win so it
was very sarcastic of course and of
course this is one position like that so
he played night 2 D 2 o 94 and you took
it
I'm just confused by why do you take it
he has too many pieces from the game we
have to reduce them at the material or
one you want - technically win an easily
won rook ending instead of having to
think instead of worrying words it's 9
is gonna go and how he's going to fork
you you're gonna invest it and then
March the a pawn and yeah now this is a
bit hard to resist especially when
there's a Queen trade coming so it was
here here I'm sure you talk talk and
then what I would just do is just push
the pawn like push push bring it here
all the data here then I bring my king
over and very hard not to win this and I
see I don't see what was the result you
won I'm assuming good very good that was
a pretty lively game I have to tell you
the guy played a very bad opening this
is a good lesson that in the Sicilian
you cannot sit idle bite this is like
it's again even if you don't cast a lot
of assets I did some sort of a race
Wieck is controlling the center of the
King side he has to do something very
active their block is trying to hold the
center normally not really initiate much
because it's hard it doesn't get d5 so
easily and move on the Queen side here
block basically got everything and at no
point if I go back if I use the the bar
to go back at no point am I seeing the
blocking in any danger not from the
opening and like some time you see
position where there's like pawns
advancing g4 g5 f5 and you were like wow
what about g6 what about f6 here there
was nothing six there was not even a
five so yeah that's not a way to play
this is saying your opponent well none
Julian whoever that was didn't play well
all right good game very good